[MUSIC PLAYING]
JIM WALSH: The only
way the planet dies
in 30 minutes or less
today is if some man who
has control of thousands
of nuclear weapons
decides today is the day.
SARAH HANSEN: Today on Chalk
Radio, the greatest threat
to human existence
and what people like
you and me can do about it.
JIM WALSH: I often
hear people say
they can't imagine that
nuclear weapons would ever
be used because it's
a mutual suicide pact.
Yeah, well, it's
important to remember
we used nuclear weapons.
We've already used
them twice, right?
So this is not something
that's never happened.
It's something that's
happened, which should indicate
that it can happen again.
SARAH HANSEN: I'm Sarah Hansen.
And in this first
episode of season 4,
we're talking about course
8.S271 Nuclear Weapons: History
and Future Prospects, as well
as the MIT Nuclear Weapons
Education Project, which is a
collection of open materials
for lectures and discussions
about what nuclear weapons are
and their effects.
So why is MIT teaching
about nuclear weapons?
And why is it important
that people like
you and me know about them?
To help explain all
this, I sat down
with two of the course
instructors-- one
a physicist and the
other a policy expert.
BOB REDWINE: There are still
thousands and thousands
of nuclear weapons deployed
by the major powers.
And the use of even a very
small fraction of them
would frankly end life
as we know it on Earth.
It would end life.
But the idea was to try to
bring this issue that we think
is existential to the
attention of young MIT
students, both undergraduates
and graduate students,
to get them interested in
it and working to continue
the efforts that had been going
on at MIT to try to get rid
of nuclear weapons.
That was our motivation.
SARAH HANSEN: That's Bob
Redwine, MIT emeritus professor
of physics and contributor
to the MIT Nuclear Weapons
Education Project.
BOB REDWINE: In 1939, the
first controlled nuclear action
took place.
And this was a real
revelation, in many ways,
to scientists in Europe
and the United States.
There was a lot of
worry among scientists.
One fear that became very
real to many scientists
was that Hitler and the
Nazis would get access
to this huge energy release that
we now know as nuclear weapons
before the Allies during
the second world war.
So there was a big push
to have the Allies develop
nuclear weapons in
case the Nazis were
going to develop them first.
And that was what
led to the Manhattan
Project that eventually led to
the two explosions in Japan.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Correspondents at air
headquarters on Guam
say there is reason to
believe that the Japanese city
of Hiroshima, approximately
the size of Memphis,
or Seattle, or Rochester,
New York, no longer exists.
[END PLAYBACK]
SARAH HANSEN: On August
6, 1945, the United States
dropped a nuclear bomb on the
Japanese city of Hiroshima.
Three days later, on
August 9, a second bomb
was dropped, this time
on the city of Nagasaki.
Hundreds of thousands
of people were killed.
It was total destruction.
It's been nearly 80 years
since these attacks,
which remain the only
use of nuclear weapons
in armed conflict.
Even so, following
the bombing of Japan,
many, many more
nuclear arms were
created by the United
States and the Soviet Union.
JIM WALSH: The planet
fundamentally changed
in the summer of 1945.
SARAH HANSEN: That's Jim Walsh,
senior research associate
at the MIT Security
Studies Program.
JIM WALSH: We invented
this awful technology.
And then our chief
adversary, the Soviet Union,
who we thought was
trying to take over
the world, they got it, too.
Our first impulse was to
build, and build, and build,
and build, both sides
approaching something
like 80,000 total nuclear
weapons between the two sides.
As Carl Sagan said,
it was like two people
sitting in a basement
filled with gasoline.
One had 7,000 matches.
One had 8,000.
They argued over who
had more matches.
What happened was, for the
first time in human history,
for the first time
in planetary history,
humans built a technology
that could destroy everything
on Earth.
There are many
challenges that we
face that could pose
an extinction threat--
climate change
and other things--
that will play out over time.
But the only way the planet
dies in 30 minutes or less
today is if some
man who has control
of thousands of nuclear weapons
decides today is the day.
SARAH HANSEN: Jim
explained some of the ways
that the course goes beyond
the basic physical science
of nuclear weapons.
He highlighted the
cultural, political,
and psychological implications
of their existence
and how, for a
long time, the fact
that countries like the
US and the Soviet Union
were stockpiling nuclear weapons
was of great concern to people
all over the globe.
Both Jim and Bob
remember the days
when nuclear Armageddon was
one of the most common fears
of the general public.
BOB REDWINE: I can
remember, in grade school,
we used to have regular
air raid drills,
where suddenly the
alarm would go off.
And you would be
told to rush out
into the corridor
between classrooms
and put your head between
your knees up against the wall
until you were told to stop.
And it's not obvious
how much good
that would do during
a nuclear explosion.
But that was what
the country was
accustomed to doing during
the Second World War.
SARAH HANSEN: And
this tension of living
in fear of nuclear weapons
came to a peak in the 1960s
during the Cuban missile crisis,
when the US government warned
of a potential nuclear attack
by the Soviet Union from Cuba.
BOB REDWINE: I happened
to be in high school
a few miles away from Washington
DC in northern Virginia.
There was a time, like on
the order of a week or two,
when we weren't sure exactly
what was going to happen.
Washington DC was
clearly a possible target
for such nuclear weapons.
It was frankly terrifying.
We thought today might be
the last day of our lives.
SARAH HANSEN: Jim explained
that this fear, the thought
of nuclear attacks
and global extinction,
eventually led to action.
JIM WALSH: At least two
periods in global history,
in the late 1950s and again
in the mid 1980s, citizens
and governments were
sufficiently scared
that they made changes.
They actually destroyed the
nuclear weapons they built.
They put themselves on a
path where things were safer
rather than more dangerous.
SARAH HANSEN: But this
progress, while meaningful,
was short-lived.
JIM WALSH: Then the
end of the Cold War
came and we sort of
all forgot about it.
SARAH HANSEN: But as
Bob went on to explain,
the threat hasn't disappeared.
If anything, it's increased.
BOB REDWINE: There are
currently many thousands
of nuclear weapons deployed.
As I think many of
you know, the power
of typical deployed nuclear
weapons now on average
is much greater than it was
in Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
If you had one of these
powerful nuclear weapons
exploding, let's
say, at a city, there
would be enormous
physical destruction.
It was enormous in
Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
It would be even more
and many, many hundreds
of thousands of people killed.
There would also be a
huge radiation problem
that would spread much beyond
the initial destruction
site that would
kill, in a reasonably
short time, many more
people from the radiation.
And in addition, there would be
a serious long-term radiation
and climate change issue
spreading around the Earth
from this explosion over the
months and years following
that explosion.
That's if there were
just one explosion.
If we had 20 to 50 explosions
of this sort anywhere on Earth,
it would basically end life
as we know it on Earth.
And we've got
thousands of weapons
deployed and ready to go.
JIM WALSH: I often
hear people say,
I can't imagine that
nuclear weapons would ever
be used because it's
a mutual suicide pact.
Yeah, well, it's
important to remember
we use nuclear weapons.
We've already used them twice.
As a political scientist
who studies deterrence
and the possible deployment
of nuclear weapons,
let me remind listeners
it's been US policy
to use nuclear weapons first in
a normal, conventional conflict
throughout the decades
of the Cold War.
Just as we fret today that
Russia might introduce nuclear
weapons because they're
losing a conventional war--
a war of tanks, and artillery,
and that sort of thing--
that was the US doctrine.
So all during the Cold
War, the US doctrine
was the Soviets had more
tanks and stuff than we
did along the European front.
We didn't have
enough men and arms
to repel a massive invasion.
So if they invaded us
with their tanks and guns
and we started to lose,
we'd use nuclear weapons.
That is our policy.
The current policy
of the United States,
its current nuclear
doctrine is counterforce.
It's not mutually
assured destruction.
It's that we're going
to hit you first and try
to take out all
your nuclear weapons
so that you don't hit us--
an incredibly dangerous
and destabilizing policy.
It's not I'll hit you
back if you hit me.
It's I'm coming
after you because I
think I can get you first.
So imagine how the
adversary feels in that.
These are just simple human
beings, like you and me.
It's not like the human race has
matured and is suddenly wiser
just because we happened
to invent something
that could kill everything.
No, we basically
shoved that technology
into our normal way of
thinking about things.
We built tons and tons
of nuclear weapons.
They did the same.
We had lots of tests.
They did the same because it was
considered a normal instrument
in a fight between
two adversaries
with the occasional second
thought-- oh my god,
are we on the verge
of killing everything?
SARAH HANSEN: While all
of this is terrifying,
it's also why the MIT
Nuclear Weapons Education
Project and the course
8.S271 were created
and why they're shared
on MIT OpenCourseWare.
The more we understand nuclear
weapons and their effects,
the better equipped
we'll be to advocate
for their dismantlement.
Much of the course is built
around class discussion.
The instructors
focus on developing
students' understanding
of the technology
and the political context
in which decisions
about the technology
are being made.
JIM WALSH: Nuclear weapons
is a topic that invites
an interdisciplinary approach.
When we try to understand the
choices that humans have made
about nuclear weapons,
we need to understand
what are their political
interests, what's
the nature of the
international competition they
find themselves in.
What about bureaucratic battles?
I think morally it's a
pretty easy decision.
I don't think anyone ever
has or will have the right
to extinguish life on Earth.
I don't think any human has it.
But as a policy matter, I can
imagine there are debates.
And so for example,
if Russia uses
nuclear weapons in
Ukraine, should the US
respond with nuclear weapons?
And I would say the
majority of the class
said, no, we shouldn't use
nuclear weapons because Russia
does.
And I'd be inclined
to agree with that.
But let's be honest.
Let's say we don't.
Does that encourage Russia
to use them a second time?
Does it send a message
to other countries
that they can use nuclear
weapons with impunity?
Very few of these choices
in the nuclear domain
are without tradeoffs
and challenges.
And so we have to
be honest about that
as we teach the course
and let students
put their chips on what they
think is the best path forward.
SARAH HANSEN: And herein lies
maybe the most important aspect
of the course, showing
students and really all of us
that we do have a say in our
future with nuclear weapons.
BOB REDWINE: I think
we collectively
as humans have no
choice but to try
to get rid of all
nuclear weapons
because as we
discussed, they do pose
such an existential threat.
It's not easy, given
the current situation.
I think we have
to do the best we
can to educate people who are
not experts about the dangers
and to encourage them to vote
and to influence their leaders
in the right direction.
JIM WALSH: Anyone
under the age of 50
has not lived a minute,
not 60 seconds in a world
where all around them the most
important issue of the day
was nuclear weapons.
You've never experienced that.
For decades, we've been told
it's the government's job, as
if the governments that
own nuclear weapons
are going to get rid of their
own unless they're pushed.
Not likely!
But when you say that
for decade after decade
and the memory fades, then you
find yourself in the position
we are today.
Everyone thinks it's
a terrible problem.
No one thinks they can
do anything about it.
And that is a problem
in their heads.
The only thing that
prevents us from doing it
is the decision we make.
And so if we make a
different decision,
then we'll get a
different outcome.
But that's the challenge.
It's the-- it's the
psychological challenge that's
the toughest when it
comes to nuclear weapons.
And that's why it's important to
remember that we've had success
and we can be successful again.
SARAH HANSEN: If you're
interested in teaching
or learning with materials
from the MIT Nuclear Weapons
Education Project or from the
course 8.S271 Nuclear Weapons:
History and Future Prospects,
please visit our website
at ocw.mit.edu.
You'll find all the
materials there.
And as always, they're free
and licensed for adaptation.
You can help others
find the materials too
by subscribing to the
podcast and leaving us
a rating and review.
If you enjoyed this
episode, you might also
want to check out our episode
from season 1 of Chalk Radio,
"Nuclear Gets Personal with
Professor Michael Short."
Near the end of the
episode, Professor Short
answers nuclear
science questions
posed by OpenCourseWare users.
Until next time, signing off
from Cambridge, Massachusetts,
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen,
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
MIT Chalk Radio's producers
include myself, Brett Paci,
and Dave Lishanksy.
Show notes for the episode
were written by Peter Chipman.
The 8.S271 Nuclear Weapons:
History and Future Prospects
and the MIT Nuclear
Weapons Education Project
online publications were
shared on MIT OpenCourseWare
by Eliz DeRienzo.
We're funded by MIT Open
Learning and supporters
like you.
OpenCourseWare will
always be free and open
for you to learn
anytime, anywhere.
Millions of people learn with
OCW resources each month.
And none of it would be
possible without the generosity
of OCW users who give
back when they can.
We hope you'll consider
making a donation
to help power free and
open resources from MIT
for learners like you.
Thank you for your support.